I love this I love the story behind it
this is one of our project sites in the
city of New Delhi in India it's a three
megawatt solar power plant it uses us
technology in terms of solar panels and
mounting structures and it also has
cells and panels made in India they used
to be a coal power plant many many years
ago and you see a lot of coal dust on
the ground right now that we have
compressed while building a project side
you've got the coal power plant that
took 8 years to build polluted the
atmosphere and you have the solar plant
in the coal pit that took 8 days to
build coal is still happening in this
country it will continue to happen for
quite a long time but at the same time
that having made this incredible
commitment to renewables and that's
really what our story is about I think
we just have to recognize coal is gonna
be part of the mix so the question then
becomes what do you do about it and this
is a calculation that India is gonna
have to make depending on how quickly
they're able to scale up upon their
renewables you can't help but be
optimistic standing here to me optimism
breeds optimism if you look at how
quickly we are building these projects
and how quickly the Indian government is
rolling out new projects is phenomenal
and unprecedented in in history and
today with 100 gigawatt commitment of
solar power in India the Indian
government is making a very large
commitment to shift the new generation
capacity towards renewable energy this
is the story right here can we just put
up a goddamn solar field when you look
at it from the top and we're trying to
improve the lives of what eventually
will be one and a half billion Indians
it seems impossible but when I saw the
solar power I thought okay for some
reason that makes it manageable you
think we can accomplish that that can be
done